hello everyone welcome to another
google+ hangout i'm really excited today
to have Calum and Cheryl with me from
the honest agency they're based in
winnipeg manitoba canada i'm here in
toronto canada so it's great to have
fellow canadian entrepreneurs guys
welcome aboard nice travelers so I've
been doing this series of you guys
watching have been a part of and I've
been talking to entrepreneurs who have
built a business around their one word
and how they found and how they applied
it and I came across this company called
the honest agency I thought I've got to
get these guys on and hear the story and
understand where the name came from and
how they're applying honors to their
business so guys where did where did the
name come from the honest agency well
it's a long story we basically we used
to be a different company we used to be
branded under a company called new host
design which I had found the mid years
well I guess in two thousand and the the
way that we had spelled the name it was
a german spelling so it's not as
actually no house design and it was
based on some of the design aesthetic
that we had at the time and what were
the years the design studio changed a
little bit in terms of our personnel and
that sort of thing and around two
thousand eight or so cheryl and i met
and we started to talk about our
different different offerings that we
could bring to a partnership and so
around 2009 we started exploring a
rebrand and a merger of our companies
and so we knew that new house had to go
and so we started exploring some new
names and new brands and to sort of a
line with how we were going to approach
the business and it it was interesting
because we took ourselves through a
branding process that we would normally
take our clients through so it was
allowing us to really get a good sense
of the turmoil we put our clients
through because you know any kind of
rebrand comes with a certain amount of
emotional baggage and a certain amount
of risk and certain amount of
trepidation in that certain so it's
great to be able to
yourselves through that process and in
doing so we went through a naming
process and you know we actually came up
with a number of names and we stuck with
we sort of settled on August really
based on on a lot of things
soul-searching and you know we wrestled
with it for a long time because honest
we knew that choosing that name would it
would mean we'd have to live up to a lot
you know once you put that name out
there people have a certain impression
or certain assumption of how you're
going to operate your business and the
type of people that you're going to be
so we actually wrestles with that a
little bit and but the more we talked
about it the more it made sense because
we thought that first of all the way
that we do business really is we do it
honestly and we come by it honestly but
also those are the things that we try to
we try to encourage our clients to be
and not just August in terms of young
being honest with their customers but
also being honest with themselves about
how they operate their business what
their business culture is like and one
of the main you know the big setbacks
people have with their brands is that
they want to be something else and they
want to be you know they want to be the
next whatever they can we get this all
the time I want to be the next Nike or I
want to be coke or I want to be dis with
that but the reality is that most
companies aren't that so we have to
really encourage our clients to think
about who they really are who their
target market is what they're offering
is how they operate their business with
their own philosophies all of those
things they have to really be honest
with themselves in order to get stronger
bread so all of those things kind of
tied together and edit you know after a
while a little light bulb went off and
it just it made sense for us to to
choose that into the too girly that's
cool what was there any it's interesting
because a lot of people I've been
interviewing have been so low they're
only founders they don't have
co-founders they started the business
themselves and in some cases built it up
to be two billion dollar valuation but
they're the only founder of the company
was that was that interaction difficult
at the start two guys to figure out why
selling on the name honest I don't think
it was really all that difficult anyway
class calculate we went through that
original process and it was a long and
drawn-out process but I think that
really the way that the two companies
came together part of what I was doing
was strategic planning internal
communications you know working with
companies at that level and Cal was
doing was working on us with the
advertising the graphic design side of
it so um the way that we came together
was that you know I would work with a
client or two around you know where do
you want to be in the next five years in
your organization how are you going to
bring that up again through the media
through public relations and to your
staff into your stakeholders into your
suppliers so I was having those
conversations with people and we get to
a certain point they feel like yes we're
really clear we get where we're going
but then they do gang how we're ready to
advertise so I called my friend Cal and
hand them over conversely he would get
clients where he would say to that they
would say we want an ad campaign and
he'd say well where do you want to be in
two years things like on at all so he
would call me and I walk her through
this process so it became quite clear
that filling both sides of this and
being able to get how people get really
clear about who they are who they want
to be what they want the reputation to
be internally and externally and then
taking that out in a pilot to a brand
made sense and it wasn't it became about
that integrity about who you are on the
inside and who you are though he's
looking and then what do you talk about
it what is your story love it is that is
honest is that something that you feel
has always been within both of you that
gots a trait that going back to earliest
days you've always tried to be honest or
is it something that you know is new or
and you feel like hey this is something
that's important in business um well
yeah I mean you know when you're when
you're a kid you're motifs honest as a
kid can be um and I think you know as
you grow older you start to you start to
I think evaluate what your understand
more about what your value stand for and
so I think as I've been getting older I
I do start
look at those those values and I start
to I think feel that having honesty or
treating you know treating your life and
your Pete the people in your life with
honesty and integrity and authenticity I
think that has become more valuable but
I think for me it was a growing process
you know it wasn't something that I was
conscious of at a younger age are you
searching yeah me too me too um I think
that really it it comes down to what you
know what are the things that become
important to you and I think a lot of
times when people are quite young may
have a really strong sort of ethnic
about some of those things that and then
they get into you the workday life and
all of the regular things and then after
up you know a couple years you stretch
to come back and say really and I am I
still do i set out to be originally and
make some of those course corrections
and you determine that you know this is
you are and this is what you stand for
and that list of who you are what you
stand for it starts to get narrower and
narrower but also in a better way so
rather than not in a closed minded way
of i'm only going to do these things or
be these things but really to say there
are some a couple of core things that
are important and i'm going to apply
them Sir got it I wanted to ask you
about your logo it actually just
disappeared from that screen I'm going
to most distracting me there you go and
I mean you guys are are into design and
so I know you put a lot of thought into
a logo creation in the font and the
colors and the star can you talk about
that and what that that means to you how
it represents your brand so the you know
along with the whole rebrand and the
renaming and everything the logo took a
really long time and it's funny because
the designer that the main designer that
was working on it is no longer with us
but you know he spends he spent days
upon days picking a haunt and tweaking
it and you know finessing all these
little nuances and the you know the
Senators and all
of these things so it was interesting to
see just how much effort went into the
actual development of the typeface
itself and then you know we've got the
asterisk in there and working on you
know what style asterisk is it going to
be how many points is it going to have
and what's you know there was so much
work that actually went into the logo
that when you actually look at it now
you're like it's almost time people to
realize just how much time was spent on
it but then but I think it shows just in
that alone it shows the integrity that
we put into all of our project because
although you can just slap a typeface on
you could slap a you know any old icon
or asterisk or our case now it's just
you know we could have slept almost
anything up there and been fine with it
but you know we really I think in order
to get the best out of any project you
really have to put that time in the
effort into it you have to you have to
feel as though you're putting your best
into it and again that you know
translates into i think the whole
philosophy of honest where people
working with the client it's the same
thing you know where you know we always
want to do the best we can for the
client and achieve those objectives for
that so I think you know in a very
long-winded sort of way I think of
reflects that that's a good 20 wow what
does the asterisk singing to you guys
why are the asterisks uh the after well
it's funny the asterisk kind of came I
thinking we come at it from two
different directions and what does a bit
tongue-in-cheek and the other is
actually sincere and basically we always
we always envisioned that the artist
name was a was a it was a punch line but
it's basically the follow up to almost
anything that we do so you know if we're
we're going in and say you know we'll do
the best we can for you you know you put
an asterisk at the end of that really
the fulfillment is honest like will
honestly do that for you and that's
that's basically where that came from
and then we also had like a little bit
of a tongue-in-cheek thing where you
know there's this truth in advertising
be aware you know are you ever really
honest so we kind of took it took a look
at it in both directions but really it's
a sincere it's a sincere but no to all
of the work of use that's cool i like it
i like that i thought it was like a like
a North Star something when I first saw
that's cool as an astro explanation um
this is getting questions from our live
viewers they want to know why what
inspired you to build your business what
inspired you the launches thing and
become entrepreneurs came from Omega
glitching oh he went so well um
personally I think my inspiration being
entrepreneurs that came from an
entrepreneur family I spent a long time
working in government which had a lot of
really interesting things and I a lot of
learning curves and get a lot of things
and a lot of different places but it
became time to to keep something on my
own to do something that job I've just
felt more natural to me um I feel like I
you know the advertising has always been
my blood communications always been in
my blood and doing this as an
entrepreneur was always something that I
wanted to get to let some point in my
career and I think for me it's it's
similar my my dad was an entrepreneur as
well so I think I always had this I
think working for other people was
always a bit foreign to me this idea
that not being you know not being sort
of the boss or whatever was always a bit
of an odd an odd thing for me although I
didn't really necessarily recognize it
when I was that young but um but I you
know I worked at an agency for few years
right out of school and I think I
discovered really quickly that i didn't
really working for the people didn't
speak very well and it wasn't anything
against my employers or anything like
that I think just there's something in
my brain that just has a it's a
fundamental thing in there that we
understand we understand the best
clothes and then well yeah and then you
know we we were lucky when we started
first company in two thousand that we
had some clients that were really
interested in coming along with us to
start our own agency her own design
studio and it just made it very easy to
make that decision and from that it's
just a we've been doing this for 15
years and edits didn't it's been great
great another question coming in the
live chat basically asking about your
sales process advice for selling clients
and getting people to reply to you and
uh you know the agency business is ultra
competitive how do you do things
differently how do you use honest to
open up doors and get people responding
to you and closing deals for the most
part I think clients come to us by word
of mouth a lot of the time and we you
know we feel like that's ideally what
you want to do and we aspire to create a
half a client because they are
ultimately well they will be having but
they're going to turn around and a
dimension that to somebody else and
that's really a lot of the way that we
move people through I think the
interesting thing about the ad agency
businesses that people come to you as so
many different phases of their
understanding of what it is they're
doing what they want so they might come
in as a brand new start up and watch the
moon burberry for a very small amount of
money and have no a very limited
understanding of what that requires so
we spend a lot of time educating people
when they come in to vote so what what
that is what you need to be and what
that investment is your company because
realistically you know these are things
that that you need to invest in the
that's time with the other end of the
spectrum is people who come in and say
you know we need whatever some small
solution fees they want to brochure well
really what's going on well my staff
won't understand anything wait a minute
how does that how do those do things get
together and make any sense so we spend
a lot of time talking people about what
it is that we feel might be the solution
to the problem that they may or may not
have articulated so where else the sales
process is really getting to know people
really started to understand where
they're coming from what the fundamental
challenge they want to see universities
and a lot of times they don't come in
with that perspective when you begin so
that's really for us part of we're on a
start is having a real look at what do
you need and what do you need to do now
what can you work the interesting thing
to with respect to our name and our
brand is that we've had clients that
will come to us specifically because of
our name and they're intrigued and
they're interested to know you know you
know very soon whether this conversation
sort of how did we come to that Latin
you know what makes us honest so they're
actually intrigued by that and I think
they're drawn to us you know really a
lot occasionally based on the name a
little and then there are other clients
who I mean it doesn't it doesn't seem to
resonate with them at all and it's just
it come to us because they've heard that
work you don't get it what we do or
we're get to work with or you know we
offer the right services for them so you
know every client is a little bit
different in how how you approached us
or how we approach them and you know
sometimes we will if we know enough well
the planet before we approach them you
know we'll prepare will prepare a
presentation based on this around the
concept of honesty if we think that
that's that's going to resonate with
them but you know the reality is that
there's a lot of clients that don't I
don't think they fully understand what
that concept is and even if it's
explained to them it given where they
are in this point is went to tie it
doesn't necessarily love me the other
thing that's interesting that we find is
that up because of the work we do in the
people that we work with now and because
of the name we can to attract
like-minded people so that's an
interesting thing you're finding more
and more that our clients are similar in
philosophy and so they're drawn to
they're drawn to us I think by initially
by the name but really because you know
we have similar philosophy so we spend a
lot of time working with companies with
you a fair bit of corporate social
responsibility with companies who want
to expand
that parameter or they want to tell that
story a little bit more and so that's
really it's really finding people who
shared or six let me guess it lets a
client self-identify right at they they
see the name and they love what they say
l there's no honesty in the ad agency
business and here's these this this
couple here the powerhouse
entrepreneurial venture that started up
around honesty I wanted to get to know
these guys I'm because it has it gone
the other way have you had people look
at and say oh that's that's stupid you
can't build the business around honesty
what are these guys order originally I i
I'm not sure if Cheryl's experience
dignity I've actually never experienced
anything like to my face nobody's ever
it'll come up to me and said oh that's
you know that's that's stupid that's a
garbage name or you know whatever you
don't live up to it nobody's ever said
that to my face so I think I've only
personally received positive feedback
from it and I'm always surprised when
people offer that up I don't know why
I'm surprised but I I guess for us it's
just second nature now so I don't you
know I don't consciously think every
time I walk through the door aw you know
we're in we're in an honest environment
or anything like that it's so I'm always
a bit I'm always a bit taken aback when
people kind of talk about it in a really
favorable way or they show more than
average interested it interesting
another question coming in techno Tut is
asking about your team how do you hire
for honest um of course lie detector
test yeah there's the torture chamber
and then um I think a couple of things
of course you know as anyone would hire
for design skill we hire for talent we
hire for writing skills we know those of
the things that you're always going to
be looking for um we very early on and
set up a description and early of what
we want this company to be in who we
want who we want it to be and what we
wanted to be like when you walk in the
door every morning and we did that
collectively with the group of people
who were witness at the time and they
determine what they want their workplace
to be like and what they want how they
want to interact with co-workers and how
they want to live and we you know since
got over that a couple of different
times with with you know iterations and
different staff and it always comes out
to be relatively the same i mean people
want to be respected for their talent
people want to have the opportunity good
to you to scan behind their work and
have it be respected but then also how
to be improved upon if that's what it
needs so we set out purposefully to hire
people and to have conversations with
people when hiring them but this is our
culture and this is what's expected and
this is how we match the movies reform
do you have a process or favorite
question that you asked to find people
who are not only good at what they do
like great at writing but may not share
the same values how do you I do wheat
those people out the people look great
on paper but may not share the value fit
with you what kind of music you like
that's interesting so what what is
honest music sound like you know what we
we do have questions like that and we
asked you know what you what you do in
your spare time what kind of music you
like you know do you follow any
particular designers or you know we
asked I think more questions that are
not maybe typical of you know you
typical interview questions and the
reason we do that is because you
although we're not looking for somebody
to say oh I like you know we don't have
an honest platelets basically what I'm
saying so we don't look for somebody
that's going to say oh I like these
artists or anything like that but you
know you can often tell when people are
answering questions like that whether
they're giving you something that you
may think you want to hear or that is
sincere to them and you know if somebody
came in and said I only listen to opera
and you know that says something about
that person and it you know it's uh it
doesn't necessarily mean that they fit
in when they don't fit in it's really
just trying to I think pull them out of
their shell as we're having these
interviews so that you really get a
sense of who that person is and because
we're a relatively small organization
you know our corporate culture is very
important and if you get somebody in
here that really
match or doesn't fit their best
insurance and when philosophies you know
it shows up really quickly and you know
to be honest we're not very good at
firing people so most people hanging
around a long time it is where you down
LOL till you break down that then you
know ask them to leave so you know we
have to be really careful decisions
initially and we and we bet those people
with those types of questions so that
you know we really understand who that
that person is we try to get to their
personalities as as deeply as we have
this little a banter happening on the
chat where you're somebody on your
social media team wrote in the same that
they also have beer fridays yeah we have
beer fridays why do mondays to heal
Tuesday's not just sharing your ideas
are pretty poor yeah that's cool so
you're not so much looking for the right
you know the right answer on what kind
of music you listen to you're just
trying to see if their answering their
answering the questions honestly you get
a sense of who they actually are instead
of just trying to fake their way through
an interview yeah you know we look for
authenticity and you know the group of
people that we have working here
currently they're watching so I can't
say anything but you know they're in a
waiter they're kind of an eclectic your
neglected group in terms of personality
right and so you have some that are more
outspoken you have some that are more
aggressive and you know talking about
not you but you know and and so like all
of those personalities come together to
create a really good mix of people and
they're not all they're not all this
they're not all clothes of each other
there there are just a complement each
other part of that is you know that that
question about authenticity is really
also about a gear if you're going to be
authentic in yourself then you have to
allow that you sorry what happens I
believe is that we end up giving each
other route to be more real and I think
people appreciate that and part of the
diet is you know not trouncing with too
keen on somebody's idea and trying to
you know be respectful in that process
but really just you know it's not about
being perfect it's just about being
really good
they don't do they have do you have a
process where they come in and work with
the team or they're there you know they
have a trial period where they get to
mix and interact where it's not just
interview so how does the what does the
onboarding process look like to get into
your culture he lies yeah I mean you
know where we've got a no we don't have
anything like that we don't invite them
for lunch have them hey oh people or
anything like that um you usually
depending on the position that we're
hiring for you know our art director
might sit in and she's got a lot of
really good insight into people so you
know we depending on the position we
might have different people in on the
interview process and we can get a
pretty good sense of whether somebody's
a good fit or not at that point but you
know he goes just a three month term
position or a three-month probationary
position you know that's all it is HR
sir please your honor question from Tim
coming in about us be unique selling
proposition and I guess that's something
you do for clients to write you help
them get the word out about their USB uh
and ideally messages that are out there
related to a value that a company has
can you talk about that that process
that you work with companies to develop
their USP and how you put that through
through their branding in their their
their advertising I talked about well
are ok I'm going to do a little catch
are you risking your neck is if you know
we're spending a lot more time working
with organizations that are doing
corporate social responsibility and now
actually we're starting to work with the
new data process that allows us to the
line are our clients messages with
different market segments if they
haven't been able to reach before around
the things that they're already doing
the end corporate social responsibility
so there's a lot of companies who are
spending millions of dollars doing
wonderful things and they're they're
spending hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars
most wonderful things and the message
you can take me mark and we can show
them out of it to the messages are and
we can show them where it can and how it
can so that's a neat prospect for us
going forward intrinsic unique selling
proposition for us to help our clients
find their unique selling proposition is
really again it's a painful it can be a
painful process because we keep drawing
it down and drying it down there's that
old saying I would have written a
shorter letter but I didn't have time
people start telling you all of these
wonderful things that they do and being
able to instead of push away all of the
extraneous things to get to that one
little nugget of what it is that they
haven't do this week they're willing
standing height it can be a long and
difficult process yeah there's you know
there's some clients that are actually
more receptive receptive to the idea and
others you know it sounds like it should
be good sokol marketing 101 but you know
some clients you know they have an idea
what it is they do and they're
comfortable with not necessarily
articulating it from the shortest most
succinct way possible there's clients
that you know will kind of keep going on
and and not even watch the entertaining
idea of developing a u.s. even though
they have it it's just a matter you know
not wanting to spend or not feeling like
the editor our ticket so you know we get
those types of clients as well but
really when we're working with a client
who understands it and understands the
value of it it's a you know really is
about getting the right people in the
room to discuss it you know it could be
a group of stakeholders anywhere from
management to people that work in you
know their staff kitchen or whatever you
know people that have a good insight
into the company and what makes them
different what makes and you know
getting those people getting their
opinions and then really working it
through that way and then willing down
all those ideas that they come with to
that really succeeding relevant point
have you ever had to make
off decision around honest where it may
have sacrificed the revenues or
profitability of the business or you
know may not have been a typical smart
business move but but it backed up
everything you stood for whether senior
decline or letting somebody go or yeah
we're well there's yeah it was been a
couple one in particular we were working
with the quite a large arts organization
here and it was it was a struggle the
person that we were working with
directly we found to be very difficult
to work with and I think she found a
simply difficult to work with and he got
to the point and they were you know they
were a sizable quiet for us but I got to
the point where working with working
with them connecting our culture was
taking a toll on our culture and it was
taking a toll on the people at worked
here and and it got to the point where
it was it was what we what we did was
abusive so in order for us to
maintaining our culture and for in order
for us to really rally behind the
individuals that had to work with this
person we had to we had to let them go
and we were very specific and direct
about why we were letting them go as a
client and it was tough because we don't
you know we don't automatic like you
know especially one that is worth you
know X number of dollars to us but
realistically we knew that it was
damaging or our culture and his damaging
business and and it was unacceptable to
pay that this person was treating our
staff as as management and as leaders
you know at some point you have to take
a stab and that was it that was a very
extreme case and it's not something that
we get into that off but that was that
was my situation yeah cancel I mean it
shows it shows not only the external
world but also your team that you guys
stand behind the brand and what you're
building here yeah I want to be
respectful of your time the people are
writing in saying thank you for all the
honest answers so
great maybe like one last question can
you talk about one of your most
successful projects people curious about
what you're doing um yeah we could
success is measured in a number of
different ways so there's there's you
know there's a client that I can think
of that we feel was very successful from
a creativity point of view and an
awareness building point of view
partially it was because I I video is
successful because it's also very
controversial I don't know if you yeah
well for me I think we're working on
over the we're actually partners in a in
a venture called activist which is fully
around changing the way we live with
water and saying our rivers and lakes
here in Manitoba we're pretty excited
about it because we manage to you rather
than just being a communications
function and also in beds itself in our
society and lots of different ways so
we're working in many many ways to get
into the school assistance getting to
government get into business in into
homes to change the way the things that
we're doing with water our success today
is that we attracted the attention of
the United Nations and a CEO of
Rockefeller consulting out of New Yorker
they're working with us now on this
program to do a pilot project cheaper in
Manitoba to see whether we can actually
affect the kind of change that we need
to do here to save our water which then
we can affect change here we can
replicate it any of you world so we're
we talked about that what's very cool
about that story is a lot of times when
I would ask something like that people
would say the campaign so she you know
guys like you who are advertising agency
they talk about the campaign that
brought in the most sales and make the
most money and here you are talking
about your favorite campaign being one
that had an impact the positive impact
in the world somehow um which is very
cool I think that speaks a lot to your
company and the culture that you're
building they're great you know we went
a little bit over but I thank you so
much for the time for people who want to
learn more about you and Ricky well with
is your website or social media where is
the best place to learn about the honest
agency welcomes a call it's actually
um no I mean or our website we've got
all of our social media links on the
website probably the easiest easy
straight to go and you know feel free to
email us at hello Otto state agency com
cool I put the link in the description
so you guys can go check them out thank
you so much for your time I really
appreciate it enjoy the rest of your day
and again just thank you for making that
time for me today alright it's ready
already take care